good evening everybody
the times half-past seven so we'll make
a start warm welcome to members of the
public
I'll start by reading the emergency
evacuation announcement should we be
required to
by the nearest available exit to the
chamber our assembly point will be in
the public car park at the side of the
Civic suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff and please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded can also
please ask members and members of the
public to turn off mobile phones or put
them onto silent thank you very much on
to the agenda item number 1 which is
apologies for absence we have apologies
from councillor
miel any other apologies there are none
substitute members we have counselor
Weston and counselor Lucas Gill and non
members attending counselors sparing row
steps oh and mrs. Hawaii at this state
members if I can just ask as councillor
Milne has given his apologies for this
evening's meeting and I don't have a
vice chair
I have asked counselor dr if he could
take up the position of vice chair just
for this evening just to assist me I'm
assuming nobody has got an issue with
that no I agree with that chairman thank
you if members are happy with that can I
was cancelled right to join me just to
help me this evening thank you
moving on to agenda item number 4 which
is minutes of the meeting held on the
4th of April 2017 the minutes have been
circulated and that's been a while and
obviously since this meeting our members
happy for me to sign those minutes thank
you very much
all right so number five to receive
declarations of interest councillor mr.
Mason Thank You chairman I have to make
a declaration that none of the green and
roxxor District residents members
present even those who are non-voting
are not which this evening thank you
very much
councillor Newport
Thank You cancer Stanley
okay can social
Thank You counselor Drake item six mr.
chairman by vote should be a member for
a detail Council thank you very much
as I need to declare interest in item
six by virtue of being a member of a
detail Council and also for residing in
the area the next item is obviously
number six which is the air quality
action plan haven't discussed the agenda
this evening if members are in agreement
as there are members of the public here
this evening we will look to bring
forward item ten to this section of the
meeting our members happy with that okay
thank you very much so agenda item
number ten which is the investigation
into issues raised by the petition
presented counsel the 25th of April is
to consider the information gathered at
the meeting of the review committee on
the 1st of June 2017 members would have
had circulated to them a summary of the
questions that were asked on the evening
and the answers that were that were
given and I hope everybody's had a
chance to have a look at those I am also
aware that there's been further email
sent in to some of the counselors with
some questions I think that may be
raised this evening by some of those
counselors so I think we'll start this
agenda item by asking if anybody has any
any further questions that they want to
raise all recommendations I want to make
or counselor mr. Mason
but we've got a microphone the season
even though I'm not really need it okay
this is my view and this is what I would
like to see the review community
reflecting its report and
recommendations to full council I know
this won't please the petitioners but
having considered all the matters and
other evidence that I have seen about
the level of homelessness of general
homelessness in our district it would be
undesirable for residents to continue to
be placed in BMV in Southend pitsee
Harlow or even Kent and I think it's too
late to make a change to the
rearrangement for tendency of or to ask
sanctuary to consider a change of
tenancy for Francis cozy Lodge and
Clarence Clarence house I was a little
surprised to learn from the previous
meeting where questions were asked that
the initiation on this change was made
by officers of blocks for district
council to sanctuary it wasn't a
sanctuary initiation and that's a fact
and that's a finding in my opinion Sammy
I was a little surprised that this
wasn't flagged up in detail at the
extraordinary full council on the 8th of
June 2016 and more particularly because
the item was in exempt members couldn't
consult with the public and I think that
was a failing of the council to to leave
members in a position where not only was
it wasn't flagged up in board for
detailed consideration but it was fairly
buried and
in a very detailed report of variation
that members wouldn't have been able to
raise it with the public engaged public
opinion anyway I I learned from from
questions that I'm not at all sure what
the role of odd or committee members in
the Oxford Housing Board or now the
Oxford Committee for sanctuary I think
it needs clarification and I don't know
whether they represent sanctuary the
council residents or just themselves as
individuals reference was made by
councillor Lumley that the matter of
report back would be discussed at a
future Rochford committee meeting and I
think that my recommendation would be
yes they must report back in future but
the carries clarification required what
role they actually play I was concerned
chairman in answer to my question that I
didn't get a very clear understanding
with 75 early people on our housing list
as to what the plan is
for housing elderly that need assistance
with with with housing and I think that
needs to be a recommendation to full
council that such a plan is elucidated
and reported to full council by the
housing options offices and finally
German the nomination agreement I would
like our offices in housing options to
put together in a report to go to full
council for full council to decide what
terms are actually going to apply to the
nomination agreement so those are all
the things chairman I'd like to be
reported as findings and recommendations
I'm sure there will be additional ones
from other members and obviously we can
all take a view
now we see those as the reason proceeds
okay thank you cancel mr. Mason
counselor Stanley Thank You chairman
first of all the questions that were
asked there were three questions that
were asked to the Action Group if you
like and they gave their references to
that at no time was the was there art
was there questions answered
specifically which I found very
disturbing from the wall counselors
alone of which one indicated that he was
only interested in the money value of
the transaction which which goes to say
that really is the harbor wall
counselors working for our DC and the
residents of our DC or are they working
for their the sanctuary who who have
taken over the properties several things
come to light where there was suggested
or it was said at a full council meeting
that there was only one resident in the
property at that particular time which
was some the last full council meeting
which you will know and and yet there
was for residents in there and as from
the last meeting that we had there was
two residents left in there so the
situation is that we wasn't told the
whole truth and yet that's what we was
given to understand from that wall
councillor I'm shocked at that as well
so that there's several inconsistencies
here and I think that we should make
sure that we're getting the right
information and I would like that noted
that we you know to get the
the right information and to get these
questions answered by the residents I'm
sure that had they have been given the
right information from the mall
counselors at the time we wouldn't have
had most of what's happened I'll leave
it I'll leave it at that
thank you okay thank you very much
counselor giving I recommend that the
review committee recommends to the
council as a valued partner of sanctuary
housing continues to provide the
information and updates for the local
residents on the changes to Frances
Cottage Lodge that's a recommendation
that you'd like to very board to move
okay
[Music]
well mr. chairman I'm a quite confused
with part the evidence that was given
sanctuary homes they stated that the
Frances launch cottage of Francis kotti
lodge was in good order
and applied by the government standards
but then we heard from council wolf and
his words were it's worked for the for a
number of years with the residence of
Francis kotti and his concerns was with
the state of the building the water
supply and water coming from two parts
of the roof so what part through what
are we led to believe was it in good
state or as councillor Ward says he had
holes in the roof and a bad water supply
that we noted counselor mrs. Mayton
Thank You mr. chairman I quite
understand the residents frustration the
way that this situation has been
supporting handled I can understand the
distress and I can understand why we
have so many people with so many
concerns still after lengthy debate I
think one of the issues stems from the
origination of this discovery when we
discovered that the initiative will
instigated by an assistant director and
not through any members not through the
full council which i think is a process
that needs to be looked at the response
is also received that not only the main
issues are not only a process which the
process has totally failed our residents
because if you hadn't found our
residents they wouldn't be concerned but
poor communication and compounded by a
lack of open and transparent reports
from both RDC representatives and the
councillor as well and again some of the
questioning at the meeting we found that
answers were not there and I was
certainly second the recommendation that
any nomination agreement now is put
forward for agreement by full council so
that we have some open transparency a
little late and it a little too late
probably but we are where we are and all
we can do is try and get the best of the
situation and hope that this type of
problem doesn't occur again and have an
hopefully have a learning curve from
this thank you very much
Canton hook one Thank You chairman and
my question or perspective on on one
expect ease in relation to potential
conflict of interest now I know that a
monitoring officer gave a viewing
relation to the
but it's in relation to all counselor
who's also portfolio order for planning
and also is on the the committee for the
sanctuary housing as to whether you know
this this is a potential conflict of
interest bearing in mind as what counsel
Mason formosans stated in relation to we
do not know specifically what the the
role is for these individuals on the
sanctuary committee
it hasn't been explained to us in
details as to what that particular role
is so without having you know full
knowledge of that there's always going
to be a potential question as to whether
there's a conflict is in particular in
review in relation to the public's
perspective and it's ultimately the
public's perspective as to whether
there's a conflict of interest is the
issue here and that's that's my point of
view anyway thank you thank you very
much
councillor hazel
you
[Music]
because we can now see that speaks of
ocean
is that emotion cancer didn't it is yet
and its seconded by Councillor hazel
could you do that for me can't look at
him I'd like to put forward the
recommendation for the committee to
recommend to the council that as a
valued partner of sanctuary housing it
continues to provide information and
updates for local residents on the
changes to Frances cottage lodge thank
you very much
councillor Stanley did you have a
question because the motion or comment
and you had indicated with it yep okay
oh [ __ ] sorry it is the motion indicated
that more informational information
gathered from sanctuary and RDC - to
come to the committee or for council
what where does it lie can't forgetting
join to answer that on okay now this is
an ongoing situation I'd like it to
continue with the council and sanctuary
as they already have a very good
partnership working agreement so an
ongoing situation okay thank you very
much that clarify that for you cancer
standing Thank You chair but not not
really because I'd like that also
included residents as well please
I'm sorry can you just clarify amend
that to not only our DC and sanctuary
but to residents that are concerned with
that I think that that does form part of
it and updates for local residents a new
EQ I think that I included in there
because it does word it and updates for
local residents is that what you mean
yeah yeah so that is in the motion
that's going put forward okay counselor
mr. Mason Thank You Jerry I
I've got to record publicly I can't
support that motion not because there's
anything wrong with that particular
motion except it's completely incomplete
compared to the issues which I think
were probably six or seven but that I
raised when first speaking therefore if
these if that is purely the only
recommendation to for counsel I shall be
supporting it okay thank you
counselor mr. hood sorry I didn't as you
time to mention I thank you my pleasure
Margaret Lee to pull rank on me there
and just spoke before me bonds very
happy with that I was going to say that
and I have a lot of problems with the
motion as it stands it doesn't really
fully deal with the issues at hand or
deals with how the council dealt with
this matter and how it would deal with
this matter in future are just echoes
the the points already made I think I
think perhaps I'd like to emphasize
mainly the the poor process and
communication in the in the first stages
the the process is for both century and
for us as a council were very poor and
we can deal with this matter property
and I think that needs to be taken back
to the council to make sure it is dealt
with properly in the future I think
board members are not the issue and
board members aren't dealt with by the
motion I'm trying to keep the motion if
you notice aren't deal with property
within the motion that is definitely
from them meeting we had on the first
adjourn I think they definitely came
across a
a feeling to me that the board members
weren't quite sure who they were
representing or who they should be
representing on the board whether it be
sanctuary residents or residents exactly
themselves they're just two examples of
why I think if else and again that
probably critical to this it fails to
address the issues around nomination
rights which I think it's just left wide
open still and the fact that from the
meeting on the first again that they
still speak just that the contract
hadn't even been dealt with it's not
even been signed or agreed neatly it's
just wide open and I think we as a
council the motion any motion before
tonight which I could agree to would
have to include all these points thank
you okay thank you counselor mrs. Mason
all factory to do anything we're putting
a motion on a third party that we have
no control over so I'm slightly
concerned about the wording that that's
aside this motion does not reflect any
of the problems that have been
discovered by this process of this
review committee the objective of the
review committee is to ask questions is
to find out what's gone wrong why it's
gone well and make proposals to redress
those problems all the problems that
have been discovered and not covered by
this motion okay thank you very much any
other comments or questions with regards
to this motion no cancel with them
Thank You chairman I've listened to the
counselors and obviously I agree on some
of what they're saying we can't we can't
turn the clocks back sanitary housing
obviously owns Francis cottage lodge and
we're given the opportunity of assisting
or helping our homeless residents which
is what we're doing because obviously it
costs a lot of money yes I do believe
that we need to look at things better
and put processes better when things
like these are coming up I want to make
a recommendation if I may on the aspect
that the review committee recommends to
council that and finalizing nomination
agreement the council ensures that
scientist cottage Lord is used only for
Rochford homeless families who have a
local connection with the initial
agreements being for five years chairman
okay thank you for council blessing we
need to stick with the first motion
okay um so there are no further question
nobody else wants to cancer mr. Mason
Chen I'm sorry I am going to ask for a
point of order Nazca our legal officers
are advised you'll notice that under
interest that we declared I declared
that the green and proper District
residents members were not going to be
subject to a whips now even those who
are non-voting are not subject to a whip
do the other parties present other
groups present have to make similar
declarations or are they allowed just
simply to have a silence on the subject
yep I have been advised that if members
have been whipped then they are to
declare it canceled the hook way just
for information the you kick group have
a long-standing policy of a no whip
system thank you very much cancer Lucas
kill okay thank you very much counselor
mrs. Mason
like so inefficient as ever right
it was it was decided some time ago that
that would be an agenda item and it
seems to be lost the lovely melting so
perhaps we can reinstate that too it is
absolutely clarity that members of the
review committee should not be whipped
thank you thank you yes you just notice
that so we will make a point of making
sure that women occasion returning to
the motion is on the floor at the moment
has been proposed by councillor Gooding
and seconded by Hazelwood I don't
believe there any further comments or
questions because
you
we do need to take a vote on that motion
so is everybody happy first with the
motion as in the wording they're all
aware of what they're voting for
if I jump between again the motion is
that Review Committee recommends to
council that as a valued partner
sanctuary housing continues to provide
information and updates for local
residents on the changes to Francisco C
Lodge members in favor of that motion
could you please indicate raise your
hands seven and members against the
motion at seven I also vote against it
you so it's lost I'm afraid there is a
second motion on the floor I believe
that has been proposed by councillor
Western do you have a second councillor
wesson favorably on Second Council
Williams
second up and can you just repeat what
you would like that motion three and the
reason of committee recommends to
council that in finalizing the
nomination agreement the council ensures
that Francis cottage Lodge is used only
for watchbirds homeless families who
have a local connection with the initial
agreement being for five years
okay thank you very much anybody can
tell mr. Mason's answer once again I
have to repeat that that motion does not
cover all the matters that I believe
should be put before full council for
BIR action and an clarification is only
one of the items that I put forward it
doesn't include a plan for the elderly
requiring accommodation
where this one has been lost it doesn't
cover issues of reporting back from the
Rockford board which we submit members I
don't know what the role of those
members are and that needs to be agreed
by full council and I think full council
and look needs to look at why the matter
was in exempt so members couldn't
consult with the public though I should
be voting against the motion
Thank You councillor Stanley Thank You
chairman as already indicated on the
first of June when sanctuary was here
they was asked that very very same
question that that was and a counselor
or a member was sitting up there where
you are all hungries I forgot my name
but she it was that the question was
asked by to sanctuary for reference to
the five years term and that was spoken
about and also for residents of Raley
only for residents of rady of which the
chairman or if you like of sanctuary
term and said it would be so I don't see
any reason why we need to put this
motion in context because it's already
been stated that it will be for the
residents of Rayleigh and I take I take
it that he has made that agreement with
RDC thank you Jim thank you councillor
mr. Roy Thank You chairman I agree with
the cause by Casso standing by
councillor Mason and I'd like to say
that I find the the motion itself
probably inadequate again unfortunately
it probably gives less rights than were
previously the case on the basis of the
motion as I heard it will take away
nomination rights from Rockford Council
it would it would just give the
nomination rights to Rockford housing as
well which make them much at housing
have low lowest though it
criteria than the media author he also
fails to make the council learn from its
mistakes there's nothing going back to
the to the council to say that we did
something wrong we didn't fully
appreciate what was going on and we and
we're not taking any measures to address
that at all in the motion so on it I
endorse the coins by previous counselors
Stanley and Mason and I can't support
the motion it explains okay okay thank
you I can't the Western yeah thank you
for chairman and I believe that we're
dealing with the Frances Cottage Lodge
recommendation this evening any other
points that have been brought up I
believe should be separated from this
motion I quite understand the questions
that have been put forward for before
haven't been answered properly and I do
believe that it's a separate issue
altogether to do with you the question
to do with elderly people who are I can
never understand about nearly person who
is homeless anybody who is homeless is
as we say you have a local connection
will be within this recommendation we're
not just saying people who are under
excuse me 65 and on 65 this is for
anybody who is homeless this
recommendation
thank you chairman Thank You councillor
mrs. Mason right talking to it that's
deep this issue is not covered by the
5th investigation and so you can't
confirm one part of it and all the other
issues that they all the other issues
that have arisen were part of this
investigation part of the examination of
the process the failure to communicate
and the lack of transparency with the
accept papers you can't isolate the bits
that you want and ignore the rest the
whole thing has to be voted on the
recommendation is expands and obviously
recirculated
is flawed the recommendation says that
in finalizing the nomination agreement
the council ensures that Francis Cote
lot is used only for Rochford home
homely homeless families who have a
local connection however Rockford
homeless families are not necessary on
our Housing Register and I would have
assumed that the council would have been
tended this to be the residence of the
district that are on our Housing
Register as this motion stands it could
be for any Rockford homeless family who
have a local connection in because
that's undefined on our Housing Register
it is defined because it's defined
before they're on our Housing Register
so this opens it to anyone having
nomination right so again the
recommendation I notice possible
recommendation that it's being made is
flawed in that it's not accurate enough
and it certainly doesn't encompass all
the problems and all the situations that
Celtic John Mason has so eloquently
listed as have other councillors so I
can't support this as it stands Thank
You council hook one and I'm going to
find them but I'm probably going to be
repeating some of what councillor
Christine Mason's already stated this
this was brought before us as an issue
which we've investigated and we have to
look at the evidence that's provided to
us and that therefore then takes us into
a number of different areas if the
evidence provided that is given to us
raises questions into other areas then
it's for this committee to look at that
and to look at it as the whole so
although I I feel that the motion
attempts to narrow this down to
something specific I think that we are
right as a committee to follow the
evidence follow the investigation and
to find recommendations that cover all
the issues that have been brought before
us thank you thank you no other members
have indicated to speak so if we can go
to a vote on the motion that has been
proposed by councilor Western and the
members want me to read that out well
you happy this printed so you okay with
that okay so members in favor of the
motion that's we've put before us please
raise your hands seven
and members against seven and I will be
voting against as well it seems to me
that the recommendations have the two
promotions that have been put forward
valid but possibly not on their own I've
got here from notes from the seasons
meetings I think there are four further
separate recommendations that members
with one foot forward possible to the
two motions that have been put forward
so I've just taken some advice to see
whether or not agreement would include
all of them so there would be the one
put forward by councillor Gooding and
council Weston in addition a
recommendation regarding a plan for the
elderly which I'm assuming you are
referring to this specific elderly sorry
let's distract again elderly residents
that are for homes accommodation jerem
to respond to your question when I when
I made a list of my recommendations I'm
including all those elderly people who
are registered on our housing register
and I think it's 75 yes okay also noted
a recommendation with a pause him back
to full council which was something that
councillor Lumley raised and that would
go forward as a recommendation that that
would be a procedure that was put into
place recommendation regarding the
nomination agreement which I think it
really is covered by the proposal that
council Western put forward regarding
the nomination agreement for five years
and that it's for Watchers homeless
families only with a local connection
okay bear with me and I'll come back to
that and the other one was with regards
to the position of sanctuary board
members whether any others I will come
back to the one with regards the
nomination agreement so we have
nomination agreement the elderly
reporting back to full council
sanctuary board members position and
also the recommendation has put forward
by councillor Gooding and mrs. Mason you
want to talk about the nomination
agreement okay I'm talking so I was
trying to indicate there was something
else yes we should learn that the
openness and track the lack of openness
and transparency and the poor
communication has led to this problem
and that should be looked at further to
try and prevent this in the future
that's another aspect thank you very
much I have counselor mr. Hawaii Eric's
new table filter yes go ahead of my
leader this time Oh Andy - right yeah
I've had mark frightened of me I still
think counselor Weston's part of the
motion doesn't fully meet the
requirements I think quite simply what
you should be brought to counsel retains
nomination rights for the five years and
that's quite simple it meets our
criteria
it gives Rochford council the rights I
think they'll be would be better I don't
know from Council Whiston finds
unacceptable sorry counselor mrs. Benson
items like it's actually in counselor
burdens most castle versus voucher sorry
if I'm correct you can't I don't know
counselor table Isaac exact answer
missus okay thank you very much
counselor mrs. Shaw sorry sorry counsel
how could you just repeat that please
I've got to remember what I said a few
minutes ago now and that it's changed to
right for council retains its or has the
nomination rights for five years for
stoppin s that as simple as that okay
thank you do I cancel sure just
clarification on the wording the century
we don't still essentially bald anymore
that's no longer it's just that we still
sit on a committee
you're in a ball system anymore there I
had a meeting in such a meeting
yesterday and they don't have a vault it
is now only a committee just for wording
you may think because the actual
original decision was made as a bold and
then I think that they offer it was not
aboard okay that that's fine thank you
like to say okay okay any further
comments anybody else indicating speak
nope okay so I've been diverted motion
prepare which needs to be seconded thank
you very much that recommendations will
go forward regarding the elderly
accommodation for elderly people that
are currently on the housing register
the matter of reporting back to for
council nomination agreement rights for
five years and the position of sanctuary
committee members going forward
and it have you got their proposed
wording that you'd like to use for that
sorry
so it's requirement to improve
communication and openness and
transparency you can make that a finding
within your motion it doesn't have to be
something to be done it can be a finding
this is what yes overview and scrutiny
committees mostly do is mostly made by
me as a finding as is the finding that
members because the item was in exempt
on the 8th June 2016 we're in no
position to to consult with the public
its are finally thank you very much
[Music]
thank you kind of Angela's just going to
confirm the working just trying to
assist the Committee on some wording so
we clear on what recommendation you're
putting forward so we're going to break
this down so the recommendation as
seconded by and stopped me to correct me
as I go because I'm writing this down
seconded by Councillor mr. Mason is
recommended to full council a report
back on the waiting list the elder you a
team is coming of 75 coming consistent
centerfire residents to be reported back
to full council and I've got by a
housing options officer
there were two separate waiting lists
understand one was for this sheltered
accommodation and one for them yeah
the second recommendation was for now
business where I need to if it just
counselor number you want reporting back
to full council its the committee
members learning yet a back to full
council on information that they on on
their meetings yes that's what she did
I think counsel needs to receive the
recommendation from sorry I've enrolled
immense thank you so I would take that
as the second recommendation also there
was a full phone about the position of
the sanitary committee members their
role their position just be clear on
that yeah okay so you're combining those
two yeah yeah okay that'll be addressed
I think wouldn't it the subjects of
conflict of interest of interest I can
address that for you now I mean it's
hard to say what the conflicts of
interest is until we know what subject
matter is I mean members here you'll sit
on parish councils dealing with planning
applications and then you also sit as a
district member on the development
control could it be argue that you have
a conflict of interest there you declare
it as and when issues come up you come
to me for advice as to where there is a
conflict and I will give you that advice
where you should whether you should be
sitting in on that meeting or not it
doesn't preclude you from sitting on
outside body thank you
sorry going back to the recommendations
nomination right so do we get I think
that one was clarify though you see
retains but are they see to retain the
nomination rights for five years that's
right and minimum okay that's point not
recommendation for rather finding by
this committee that the lack of openness
and transparency and we are never to
learn and to look how we can friend this
new future yen requirements to improve
communications
[Music]
okay okay our members all unhappy with
that and understand the wording in that
case we need to take a second second by
Councillor mr. Mason yes and we need to
would members in favor of that motion
raise their hands and that's unanimous
thank you very much
okay that concludes that agenda item two
this evening I know there are members of
the public here that was specifically
here for that if you wish to leave you
can do so now if you wish to stay your
wipes that you're more than welcome to
stay
Emily specific concept for language
because you okay
okay members if we can we do agenda item
number six which is the air quality
action plan with regards to this agenda
item this evening we are joined by
councillor Webb who is the portfolio
holder for community and mallet
environmental health team leader this is
a calling of a portfolio holder decision
a decision was called in by councillors
mr. hoi council Newport and councillors
Stanley and the reason plan well the
plan is inadequate and does not properly
address the need and requirement to
reduce the pollution levels in the area
in addition monitoring is not adequate
to fully measure the pollution levels
everybody's I believed received the
report which is quite a lengthy document
if I can ask either or counselor mr. hoi
councillor Newport councillor Stanley
firstly to to begin council evil famous
Darren
yes the report is quite lengthy and so
I've just a few questions I'd like to
ask about the report and first question
being the cost of the report would it be
possible for the officer to give a
summary of the key changes from a last
report that was issued in 2015 and when
I was looking at the public consultation
on this report I 41 respond people
responded to it which I felt was pretty
low is that because of a lack of
publicity around the air quality in our
district moving on from that where in
the report states that we should be
meeting the objectives by 2018 is this
realistic what's been done to raise
awareness and I see some of the measures
of reducing the pollution rely on
funding and has any of this funding
actually being secured or we just simply
putting measures in that that will never
actually get implemented thank you thank
you very much
are you able to answer any of those
questions thank you very much yes
chairman and to take the pointing in
order in terms of the the changes we
obviously have to publish document that
came to review committee back in October
in terms of the changes there weren't a
great many changes but there was
refinement of the wording in particular
and certainly as the document took its
time the Essex County Council
with the actions that are attributable
to Essex County Council again we're
updated further so the clarification is
the progress of ongoing works and the
plans as they were emerging from Essex
councilors the highways offer the
significant amendment that did take
place or is engagement with Areva as a
bus company and that's one of the
[Music]
reasons for the
patient period it's my microphone fading
in and out so I hope this assist and
that that was significant in terms of
the plan to the company would like to
put in place regarding routing as well
as then the the which is effectively
looking at right turns out of crown Hill
as well as then the infrastructure re
looking at Levi's and capacity for buses
to stop without that in fact being to
the detriment of the flow of the traffic
through the town center so that's really
the the fundamental challenge plus then
the actual commentary in the report
about the consultation process and so on
with regards to the response rate it was
40 separate responses from individuals
and statute console teams including Town
Council businesses residents and further
afield in local authorities and that
included residents both within and
without the AMA the number the overall
number forty and I know that I've
corresponding with a number of members
on this compares very favorably with
other HMOs in particular
Colchester Town Council have a very
large aqm a covering their entire town
centre and they achieved I mean the high
quality to the consultation and they had
an equally strong direct mailing and
social media campaign around their
consultations unfortunately you know
response rates we can only do our level
best and I had the details about the
consultation measures we took if members
would require that so I'm as an
individual officer of the council I'm
content with the response rate that we
received we've got the 2018 figure yes
that is robust in terms of looking at
the trends of the nitrogen oxide levels
within the
Center and importantly the number of
receptors that would be subject to any
levels within that area you can see that
it's on a steady decline and in fact
it's important to note that we could you
know to consider as an option a
do-nothing policy however that's not
practical in many reasons one because it
doesn't achieve the objective in the
fastest possible time and the other is
it doesn't secure the maintenance of
that reduced level as we go forward so
we have this plan as a proportionate
document to address the issue and
maintain any improvement that we can
secure with regards to funding and you
will note that there have been changes
in the approach to monitoring across the
AMA let's realize they saving which can
go towards some of particularly the the
residential engagement the driver
engagement across the ACMA can also be
considered going forward to the
feasibility study but the number of the
measures are reliant on once the
document is approved and goes forward
and importantly the Defra supported the
we could put ourselves in a position to
lever a quality grant funding from Defra
and to take some of those more
financially expensive options forward
into the future thank you very much
does that answer your questions
councillor Newport sorry chairman Pham
my first question was what the cost of
the report was okay be able to confirm
that the cost the report to Roger
District Council was in the order of
fifteen thousand pounds one low one five
one five fifteen thousand two pounds yes
which was topped up further topped up by
Essex County Council buy and we go
north of around 2,000 pounds between two
and three thousand pounds that was using
Ringway Jacobs's day in the house
integrated highways engineers and
experts yes thank you very much sorry
that should say though that they were
secured through and what understand to
be a framework agreement that Essex
County Council already have with certain
providers for certain services so we've
recognized through by our procurement
team as a robust way of achieving this
this report okay thank you
council kidding Thank You chair can the
officer and explain how many times our
DC have hit the peak levels and of this
two hundred milligrams of it my monogram
is all de granted Micah I'm sorry I
certainly yes in the report such as your
details in the report previous to that
the latest detailed assessment so that
we do not hit the two hundred micrograms
and hourly right so this is solely and
and the annual average issue and it's
documented in within the report you can
see that we're marginally exceeding it
with a prediction that it will only be
at one location in this calendar year so
the answer is none for the hourly rate
to study the higher 200 milligram
threshold you may up
she'll show
so can you explain how this process
works and how the information is for the
game
thank you sir so the in terms of the the
approach to monitoring we use and
diffusion tubes which are passive means
of assessing the nitrogen dioxide in the
air it's a small tube that we place
against the receptor location and they
are changed on a timetable as set out by
Defra as the government department that
oversees this process we have had more
detailed monitoring up until middle of
2016 which was an order to canalize ated
in the high street to the junction with
eastwood Road
that gave us very detailed information
on
on
the minute basis and is from that that I
derived that there were no exceedances
of the hourly mean any deed goes the the
information that that's gone into this
report to tell us if we have this
marginal exceedance now only in greatest
and center for the annual average level
that answer question counselor mr. Mason
oh thanks Jim finally I heard a rumor
but the tubes pin really the receptors
you may call them have been moved if
that's the case can you confirm yes or
no and why were they moved and what was
wrong with them in the place they were
second question is about well I heard
there were 41 responses which included
static console T's and Uncle Tom Cobley
and all but I'm very interested in how
many actual residents responded and I
little surprised how low that is even
though you're satisfied because I
believe the UK as a whole as it has
actually failed to respond to the EU
regulations on air quality and most
probably the World Health Organization
so I'm just a little surprised with the
sort of general impact on the TV screen
and in our papers and everywhere else
and our doctors surgeries that more
people wouldn't have been aware I'm just
a bit like frantically large sorry
mention that the buzz word and maybe
there's a communications strategy issue
here because on those people I speak to
air quality is the first thing they want
to talk to me about so I'm a little
surprised by that so I guess I've got
the two questions about the receptors
had they been moved widely removed and
why were they in the wrong place in the
first place then number of residents and
do you think that we could do better at
communication you happy to on Thurs
you
I think that thank you and so taking
those in turn yes as indicated in in
fact in the action plan itself very
early on we talked about the changes in
monitoring that will carry out that is
explained in there but yes to confirm
the changes in monitoring we no longer
have the automatic analyzers I expressed
in answer to to cancel miss Kinney we
have increased the number of diffusion
tubes but move them away from what we
would call a roadside location so on the
pavement which where they were
previously on lampposts and we have now
moved them to the facade of residential
premises at locations near or around
those premises that have been listed
within the air quality action plan
itself there are two reasons for that
one is with the removal of the air
quality with the automatic analyzer
which is necessarily on the pavement we
had out diffusion tubes co-located with
that automatic analyzer and then for the
purposes of equilibrating the the data
then had the rest of the diffusion tube
network if you like on lampposts having
removed the automatic analyzer we can
actually put the diffusion tubes on the
facade of the receptors building so the
home that have agreed and first-hand
data there and then at the receptor so
it's just more robust if you're liking
that there is no extrapolation of data
from the road side to the facade of the
home but in terms of creating the report
that you see in front of you you'd still
have to run a computer model to get the
the red and blue areas that you see in
the plan so we've got better data at the
window and the front doors off of the
people living in the in the air quality
management area
in umeå when you say better data can you
continue explain to me what's better
about it is it better because it's lower
or is it better because that fits with
the statutory requirement I don't
understand
[Music]
better simply in that the the analysis
and the extrapolation doesn't need to be
carried out there's no calculation to be
done it's it's raw data at the receptor
so it's just it needs no more or less
accurate but it's but it's more directly
achieved in terms of the number of
residents that responded and I don't
have the final number in front of me but
I think it was in the high teens once
reflected in all of the other data so I
can certainly supply that to committee
members on to this if they would like a
breakdown I know that it's been
communicated to some of the members on
this committee already but I can make
sure the whole committee receipt it it's
probably many that I'll be one of the my
god
confirm that for the committee that
thank you and in terms of the the final
number with the communications actually
I had to break down here if members will
bear with me off quickly rounds very
what what we did
so all 223 households within the Eric
you may received a letter so I'm posting
them to the Consul in a Rayleigh chamber
of trade with a request that they
circulated it to their businesses which
they did hard copies of the
consultations were placed at our
receptions both in the council offices
and the Civic suite and in all of the
libraries across the district myself I
directly briefed the clerk to Reilly
Town Council and I know that that was
then further discussed and a Reilly town
council meeting prior to their group and
individual responses the Equality
conferred on our website as prodigious
website in the heavier say section it
also featured in the news and events say
I
so was on our air quality pages and
features on the Essex Air website we
also had it on our social media so
Facebook and Twitter and again it was
retweeted by the Essex air and Twitter
page
it was also circulated and then featured
in the local newspapers and press
releases were issued and I know that
they were published as well the rights
from Coastal Point CCG had a press
release and social media presence as
well regarding the decision and indeed
the the consultation period was extended
from the original plan four weeks to
just over five and five weeks to take in
and the Christmas and New Year period as
well and all statutory console TV van
email directly linking them to encourage
the response as well as part of the
consultation process I received a number
of emails and number of calls to which I
responded and they listened to further
contacts from others and of course with
the consultation itself we also wanted
resonance within the AMA to volunteer
their premises and the number did thank
you very much general it's going to be
one of my classic findings the finding
appears to be despite all that amazing
communication that residents don't seem
terribly interested but the world seems
terribly interested it can be a subject
I'm just absolutely gobsmacked and if
the press were here I'd love them to use
that as a wonderful headline you know
council is gobsmacked the more residents
are not interested in air pollution or
air quality um I'm actually shattered
one question if I may
put the office of find this out for me
how many hits did our website get to
that particular page during the period
and I'm not asking for it now if you
when you tell us the breakdown of the
number of residents you know all that
could you be clear you could look into
that
Thank You counselor Stanley oh sorry no
it's cause like on the backs up at where
I keep zombie no go thank you
sorry sorry Kevin thank you for that and
yes it was some time ago that we are
myself and another counselor spoke to
mr. Helmick on the diffusion tubes and
felt that the the area that he said was
going to be looked at as to the radium
Center and we felt that it should be
further out and as he well knows that
the air quality doesn't stay in the town
center it moves around and it moves down
the hill across peaceful Road and and so
on and I'm a bit disappointed that a
full survey of the area wasn't wasn't in
the report also I'm disappointed that
2016 I believe only had two to four
months of evidence and he well knows
that he can't incorporate their into his
projection because it has to be nine to
twelve months so that should have been
taken out and he also well knows that
the air quality is not good it's above
and has been above for some time the and
I would like to ask him why
this is so that this is in the report
where it doesn't mean anything at all we
and to have an average over a period of
time five years or whatever there might
be with the ingress of another thousand
homes if not 1500 homes which will
possibly have two or three cars in the
future and how you can document the
future response in 2018 will be lower
we have no cycle pathways we have no
electric plugs to plug in for electric
cars in car parks in fact there is only
one in Essex
so how you can reduce that pollution by
2018 is beyond me thank you would you
like to come back on that or can you
come back on
we've got put forward
yes I think so if I if I'm clear enough
on on on some points to extract from
that
I think the
first point is that the the air quality
management area was declared back in
2015
against what is a national objective
it's called target if if it fits me
which is 40 mic for nitrogen dioxide
it's not something we've created as a
target for ourselves so we are required
to report against that as the figure so
just just so we know what the parameters
are that we're dealing with I in terms
of many of the actions you talked about
there clearly they feature in our action
plan about the charging points cycle
encouraging modal shift you know they
are all this plan is discrete to dealing
with the air quality management area
necessarily that is whatever require and
that is what has been produced I believe
very well and with a very smooth process
and as its described a review committee
back in October if they're entering
further points that the council would
like responding
that misses Parliament response can see
under the the questions being asked is
deaf or not aware of our housing
situation and and obviously are not
aware they're only dealing with today
and not tomorrow and I don't just meet
tomorrow I mean tomorrow
Lauro when all these houses are built
and when all these cars are on the road
that we haven't and I know what the
recommendations are but surely we should
have had cycleways right the way through
the district we haven't go any charging
points as yet and with this is the 21st
century and we are supposed to be ahead
of the game I'm sure but we've only got
one in Essex and that's a long way off I
think it's in Colchester so it's a long
way to go and charge your car to bring
it back and find its discharged and
things like this that we haven't thought
we haven't got motivated to do I don't
see Defra concerning their selves I know
it's that the difference criteria that
we're working to but according to your
planes or your or your documentation is
that it is over the faulty may it be
only just over my other points by the
way is that taking these tubes or files
or whatever like I call them away from
the footpath and answer people's
properties I don't find many people
walking through the front gardens so
that's a little bit odd to me because I
usually find footpaths are at the side
of the road so therefore the health of
the participants using the footpath and
not people's front gardens to walk
through is well important other than in
putting it on a property there is 20 30
foot away I don't see the relevance of
that it should be on the footpath
because you and I have to
walk there and when we're walking up
cranium getting all that congestion in
there we're not doing ourselves any good
so putting it on a property doesn't
really sort of say the right thing to me
thank you thinking are you able to
address those point they're not specific
questions but a yes then counselor so in
first off in terms of Deborah's
knowledge and expectation of us we
obviously the air quality management
area is fallen out as for work that's
come
duties would report to deafer on an
annual basis in what's called an annual
status report that X is a effectively a
screening tool so not only do we report
in our progress but we report some
changes in the district which would
include residential developments is a
document that has a template and we last
reported back in June 2016 with that it
is annual asthma full knowledge of any
plan or deed any changes
the sick
in terms of the pathway the the what we
would call relevant scepters for the
work that we're carrying out here for
the the 40 micro level is in the houses
is that the facade of the residential
buildings it excludes roads pathways
even the front gardens to the houses it
starts at the front door and goes
backward in the property so the
diffusion tubes are in exactly the right
location they're at the the furthest
place forward if you like in terms of
where there is any relevant the the the
answer I gave earlier regarding to the
200 microgram per meter cubed level as a
peak that's relevant on the pathway so
that would affect both pedestrians and
in any anyone sitting in a cafe outside
all those people suddenly become
relevant receptors into the definition
okay thank you Jim thank you very much
counselor mr. hoi they were lost so many
people put in front of me is there are
quite a few people left to speak as well
as thank yous how heartily as quick as I
had and I was hesitant in Colleen's
reporting this had being originally the
AQ ma was originally signed off for
believing january 2015 and one of the
horrifying points about this is it's
taken since then to even get report
issued and if I point out to you because
I'm sure some members don't realize this
because they this started before most of
us here were members I think I was a
member for less than a year before they
started 2011 so this is how long it's
taken I think one of the things I'm
horrified about is that the length of
the process and I know mr. Harris I've
said that before and I understand to
some extent you are tied by what you
need to do I also understand councilor
Stanley's point about why you measure on
the runt of a house I understand the
rules but then I think your recently
read reports about the pollution in cars
the actual cars causing the pollution of
is probably one of the worst places to
be on the road so so I understand the
points
how it's making and I understand fully
it but it's just to say it's wrong in
many respects what we're reporting on if
I draw members attention to page six
point two six I'm aware that we are
report this report is only on the air
quality management area however in the
first paragraph two point one on that
page it does say in the final sentence
no current exceedances of the objectives
have been identified anywhere else in
the district of Rochford properly
because we don't measure many other
places in Rochford
I really don't like that sentence being
there it's indicating that the rich west
of rockford has no problem I really do
not believe that that's the first point
I really had trouble with that sentence
I'd be happier if he said we haven't
fully measured other parts of the
district no but where we do measure we
know it has not been exceeded and that's
quite restrictive where we do measure I
know further on the question I'm a guide
I'm a member of the Green Party I speak
to friends of the earth John fuller I
know wellies is involved in the court
case against the government
I believe the automatic monitoring is
more reliable than the diffusion trees
but understand it's also more expensive
so my concern is we've gone for a less
reliable but cheaper way of measuring
I'll leave that now it's being raised by
councillor Stanley so I leave it there
other points which have been raised by
councillor Newport sorry a lot of the
proposals on this report although all
the action points depending on funding
if I take on page six point four eight
and don't know councillor Steptoe Singh
indexers speak I don't know if he's
chairman or not of the local head at the
moment he was the vice chair no one
knows yet another council Western will
be on this at some point
however on point three changes to
pedestrian crossing points this has been
dropped by the local highways panel I
seem to remember as being too expensive
and actually not achieving very much
which I know this is these beliefs in
reality it's not depending on funding
just will not happen there is no funding
and I find that through through the
whole report I'd not everything some
things there I think the report is
something which we've written it's cost
as 15,000 pounds of counsel and I think
that the points on it are very unlikely
to make any difference to the
measurements at all because they would
either have happened already or
happening through either measures and
many of them won't happen the cycle is I
know of one new cycle route in the dish
which just happens to be along the whole
bridge road which actually didn't
actually finish the end of where it's
supposed to have finished the the local
plan where where applications being
passed they don't appear to include
cycle routes or funding or section 106
or cycle routes or where they do that's
very minimal the transport plans they're
six free tickets to six books of tickets
to to write to do residents that they're
just not achieving very much and that
that's the problem with with this report
I think it it does it says a lot of
things which are collectively sent quite
good and if they happen brilliant but I
think overall that they're going to be
having minimally impact at all even
though minimally I mean every most I'm
just on one page at random 6.5 they're
all less then no point to so
individually going to have a minimal
impact okay to claim a but most of them
just will not happen and that's the
other the problem I have with it
I did the big problem I have is that if
we're if this is a air quality quality
management plan just for the area we
shouldn't be mentioning that other areas
don't have a problem thank you thank you
again nice and make a better comment on
the on the last sentence on paragraph
2.1 if that can be changed or can you
confirm that other areas have been
monitored suddenly and the comment and a
which is safe rediff no one I'm beholden
to so yes in theory subjected advice to
take of regarding the the plan as it's
um
agreed is not critical to the to the
report however is it just a point of no
obviously we have been monitoring at
various locations across the whole
district for a good number of years now
obviously more than more than a decade
closer to 15 is that has been in a
targeted fashion and over the years has
explained at the last review committee
that I attended in October that has been
refined as well and because of the
annual reports that we put forward for
Defra if there were concerns over the
levels that we achieved the monitoring
locations and we were withdrawing sites
too early that would be featured in the
feedback from Defra it never has so I
believe that we have taken a relatively
cautious approach to the deployment of
monitoring locations across the district
and yes we do retain just a few just
it's now just down to two locations
outside of Raley Air Quality Management
Area but that also indicates the
commuter confirm another trend of
nitrogen dioxide across across the
country can you confirm where those two
locations are I can yes they're in the
public domain they one eating South
Street in Rochford and the other is at
the amberlynn junction science Sutton
Road set veterinary junction Rochford
okay so those two other locations you
can confirm that there has been no
evidence that those limits have been not
in the exceedance but we continue to
monitor them as they're not sufficiently
below the 40 microgram per meter cubed
annual average that I would be happy
with drawing those sites indeed because
of section 106 monies that would come
forward from the haul road development
in Rockford there should be some funding
to support monitoring at their location
indeed so for continuity of data it also
serves us okay so another point account
to the Hoya raise there
he's obviously more knowledgeable than I
am was that there is perhaps a a more
effective method of measuring what did
you say automatic
and so was that huge is confirmed was
that decision taken PD based on cost not
purely on cost no indeed the the lead
author of the report the principal
consultant air quality consultant
positively recommended it as he wasn't a
source of data required for the for the
extent of the issue that we have in
Riley town center and indeed we would be
better served by redeploying the
diffusion tubes to the receptor
locations the the troops that we deploy
our subject to a national bias
correction factor and an annual basis
which is obviously national in nature so
easy to robust okay thank you very much
cancel mrs. Nelson thank you thank you
to the two aspects of questioning I'd
like to enter in so firstly I would like
to look at the air quality action plan
measures we've heard about the
monitoring and how that has been changed
and then we have a list of traffic
management bearing in mind that this air
quality management area was signed in
January 2015 so we're two and a half
years down the road so I would expect to
see some positive outcomes here whether
they're under two milligrams per month
late or whatever but I read down it and
it reads more of a wish list rather than
any plan panel have decided not to fund
the next one operators to determine
whether cleaner strategies could be used
if operators to determine no current
funding no schools in Raley involved at
present promote identify appropriate
quiet rooms no cafes which is the cafe
explain no cafes in Laney at present
funding will need to be identified
likely to be implemented I've just
picked out a few at random likely to
include cycle paths we'll take a look I
mean I could go on will be looked at
needs to include could be pursued
alternative approach could be to add air
quality considerations may need to
include requirements in local plan and
so on none of the things I will be
expected after this length of time to
have a much more positive situation to
say that these initiatives have been
implemented and I can understand that
they're not all within your control but
it's it unachievable and they're a
wishlist
they shouldn't be under a traffic
management plan they should be as
something that we would like to do but
we can't do I would expect a traffic
management to show what can be achieved
and I'm a little bit concerned that what
it looks very good and I'm sure we have
someone to comment as we've paid a lot
for it but bearing in mind the effect
that air pollution has on health and it
has a silent effect and it has an effect
on the most vulnerable members like most
things of our society the elderly and
the young and the unwell I would have
hoped for a much more positive or even
though just five or six of them I'd
rather see something that we are doing
rather things that we would like to do
so how realistic is this wish list
you
thank you yes to come to your point it
is agree that some of the actions are a
concrete already in train or will
definitely happen a lot of the actions
do require a certain funding but we have
only just emerged from the consultation
process as well so that that informs
some of these I think also that it is in
the nature of the document and a
requirement from from Deford to show all
of the options we have considered and
retain those that the even if it is at
the stage of say feasibility initial
contact to to achieve them so I take
your point that that not all of the
points in here we'll get realized but we
will work towards achieving as many as
we can and as soon as we can thank you
thank you I think that answered it might
have helped is that perhaps they were
split between achieved achievable and
unachievable it might have made it
slightly better but that's just a matter
of presentation and the other question
that I'd like to raise if I may mr.
chairman is when you came to the meeting
in October and this was discussed then
at some length as wherever Li you
advised us at that time but if we wanted
other sites monitored we only had to ask
we asked we were refused can you tell me
why and who made that decision please
could you just clarify are you able see
we were advised that last review
committee in October that if we wanted
other sites monitored that we only had
12 yeah so I mean can you just confirm
where you asked for it to be or does
that just to help answer the question
that's um well it was the principal if
the principal I want to know is why when
other sites when we were told that we
could have other sites investigated that
when that request was formally made I
believe it was councillor Reeves Council
and he'll sit near pool I mean it's more
than one council we were refused and all
I'm asking is why that refusal came
after we've been assured that it
wouldn't and what why and who made it
and what was the logic behind it you
know thank you
yes it did both from counselors and from
the public there was some requests for
additional monitoring to occur around
the the district based on officer
knowledge previous data and the the
process such as we've taken it in SSA to
refined process over a good many years
the locations that were presented
would be a be an issue regarding the
annual average level for nitrogen
dioxide so it's of course of
proportionality and necessity so there
were several people are involved in
making that decision there were some
yeah yes it wasn't myself alone and I
know that had conversation forgetting
was infimum using personal email but
we've them shorts cotton as part of
those processes yeah so who had the farm
and so I think it was a mutual agreement
is in taking my advices to to the the
data and the sites that the we that we
knew off okay the answer question
council mrs. Mason Thank You counselor
sure
okay thank you very much counselor
Gooding thanks Jeff
I just want to know if firm if anyone
can carry out these these measurements
could I guess a member of public carry
out this process at all there's no legal
bar to anyone can there
of course you know it you became to get
as robust the data as you can and there
are guidelines for deploying them and
specific calendar such that they can be
robustly analyzed and corrected at a
year-end as well thank you very much
councillor Weston this is okay thank you
councillor Williams Thank You chairman
just a point really I'm not sure where
counsel certainly got his information
about charging points for electric cars
them to my knowledge within ten mile
radius there's sixteen that's not
counting that's not counting main
dealers where they will have them there
most of them have them um I think it is
a good thing that perhaps Rochford
should should consider putting them in
their car parks also new houses it
should be obligatory for them to have
charging points and I understand
interestingly from a meeting that we had
last week that the bus is now legally
have to be no no older than six years
old for that for local bus services so
this I would think would only improve
the situation as air quality thank you
thank you very much
councillor step take this chair I was
going to raise the point that can't
guess Williams raised that there are
considerable number of charging points
around the whole area and two particular
ones that spring to mind is a particular
property in shoe Bri and also the Civic
Center at South End okay thank you very
much we have still indicate
that they wish to think so if we can
keep the
you
short concise councillor Stanley Thank
You chair but it's not very often you
could if you had electric car you could
go into a dealership and use their
electricity now I don't know that you
could do that at any given time unless
you made pre arrangements for it because
I'm sure they wouldn't just say yeah you
can plug in whenever you like I've been
under fire to leave that is the case is
what plug in whatever you like this
that's amazing
good luck good luck to them that's all I
can say on the basis of the - on the
basis of recent or evaluating the
pollutants with these files in previous
years I would like to ask if the because
of the volume of traffic now is
considerably more than what it was in
recent years going back and it is a lot
lot more than what we anticipated that
surely we should have these files put
back to evaluate what they what it is
with and more than more than the two
that we understand that are there at the
moment
there is your question so my question is
should they should they be reinstated
because of the volume of traffic that
we're getting with not only the house
building fraternity that lorries and
what have you that there is a
considerable more traffic and I've
noticed that on hammerhill it the
lawyers are going past a light one every
20 minutes
well I'm going to obviously you know
we're to haul road
so should we not be put in those
receptors back ok could you address that
yes a conscious chairman that we're
going away from the report and the
discrete nature of the report which is
about Rayleigh Town Center and the
action plan for it but the summarizing
brief that we obviously have other
sources of information such as the exact
Walla tee assessments that come in with
the larger residential development
schemes and officers use those as well
to get an indication of the situation
and I have a number here both
particularly in West Raley where air
quality assessments of the company the
planning permissions our planning
applications and
data that's up to date and obviously the
the modeling that's been deployed by the
specials
so as you pointed out so just to confirm
there are no plans to reinstate any
other diffusers or monitoring equipment
anybody anywhere else in the district
other than the ones that are currently
there however that will be reviewed
periodically are you able to confirm how
often it's reviewed and we use that as a
screening tool and clearly as
developments come online and other
sources of information brought to us
that's a constant source of knowledge
and for us to analyze okay so somewhere
like for example London Road where there
is lots of development planned officers
would be aware and that would be
considered over place indeed mr.
chairman yes just briefly 190 London
Road when that was developed had an air
quality assessment as have developments
Brian timber Grove and the land adjacent
Grange villa was included within the
larger language London Road development
and yet as other sites is there with a
certain size particularly where they
require a scoping opinion we're
requesting air quality assessments okay
thank you very much so came Chancellor
standard counselling
but obviously a lot and as we all know
that death we're lost the court case and
because their mom thought the way they
the air quality is woefully inadequate
and how well is this plan this air
quality plan going to fit with the
government's new air quality plan or
will we be as we walk out here will we
be looking to produce another plan and
also and in the report states that other
areas haven't got problem in really and
we don't read in the district so you
don't really know that for a fact
because as we've heard and those areas
aren't monitored and I think that should
be removed from the report thank you
it's mr. chairman I can respond to that
with regards to the work that we carry
out here this is local air quality
management to achieve national
objectives the case with that we're
client earth have successfully taken
deferens tasks in High Court for the
inadequacies of the national air quality
plan that Deborah's work and then the
work that the secretary stated ever is
charged with for achieving the EU levels
and that means particular looks at those
glommer Asians to use the u term and
primarily looks at the larger roads
around the country so it's focused on
roads such as the O one through seven
rather than roads that you would find
obviously within the town center itself
so our work is separate but but the the
key point that overlaps here is that the
target and the threshold at the same -
that 40 micrograms per meter cubed
actually has to be for the same
pollutant and it's the same level just
in different places
I actually am meeting with
representatives of death on the 7th of
July to very to find out what the
implications of the revised national air
quality plan is for Rochford and I will
be responding back into my portfolio
holder and colleagues after that meeting
at Jerez just like add just just so need
to bear in mind here remember that the
levels of the air pollution are talking
about here actually very low in terms of
what's actually in Canada and the
response needs to be proportionate in
terms of whether the threshold is is 40
milligrams and the areas that we're
talking about is only slightly above our
community levels and then only then
within a small number of locations in
Accra I mean office done a fantastic job
renters are not only an excellent
consultation but carrying out a plan
that's been done with external guidance
as well I have every confidence in my
sister and the work that he's carried
out
thank you very much I have at the moment
I've got two two members who have
indicated to ask questions
I'm conscious at the top we've still got
quite a few bits
to go through and we have a request for
a comfort break as well so if I can ask
counselor Lucas Gill real question and
then cancel the hook way for the moment
if you can Thank You gentleman just a
very quick one Southend Airport have
measuring equipment near the end Berlin
and another set of equipment just
outside the Rockford boundary do they
report the figures to the council thank
you yes indeed both those data and both
one location within the Rochford
district and the others just around the
main surface access to right surface
access to Southend Airport are reported
directly to officers at ROG for them
Southend Council I believe they're also
published as part of the annual report
there's certain airport producers thank
you thank you very much cancel hook way
Thank You chairman my question is in
relation to the sensitivity of the the
equipment and the extrapolation of the
data from that if it are you able to
identify Peaks on to related to specific
days and times in respective that
obviously air quality is affected by I
imagine there's a seasonal aspect to air
quality and there's also a sort of like
a weather aspect to to air quality so
are you able to identify any correlation
between those various different things
in relation to the peaks and the data
yet mr. chairman yet the answer the the
automatic analyzer that we used to have
would record that the data on the units
is described earlier that would see
quite a sensitivity and show the peaks
and troughs because the levels that that
was coming up were nowhere near the 200
micrograms per meter cubed on an hourly
basis there was no justification really
to keeping that any longer the diffusion
tubes because we're looking at an annual
average will only give us the
effectively a monthly there's are there
a four or five week period average so
yes we do see seasonal variation we
would also answer that if we know there
are roadworks of right diversions and
those sorts of things we would see a
change in the data produced and
obviously that's where the local
knowledge comes in as well but no we
wouldn't see any more sensitive to that
and to take into account episode your
rain showers or those sort of things and
how they may influence the data again
we're looking at an annual average so
actually we can have quite coarse data
that is robust
thank you
if we can take final questions from
counselor mrs. Mason and then counselor
mr. Hawaii okay Thank You counselor mr.
hi thank you Jim it was less a question
more of a a statement maybe it was plain
Tuffy was probably cast to show us what
we as Catholics call Dean we're hoping
to get out of it I think for ourselves
for sort of fun find out what the issues
were my big problems have I've said
nothing other counselors recognize this
that he's taken an awful long time to
produce this report and I was hesitant
in calling it in because it has taken so
long however I fell to the five days
maybe it would delay a week or two weeks
that's fine to get to an understanding
of it but I think perhaps if we go back
to what counselor
mace was saying on a previous subject
perhaps we we as a review committee
could issue a couple of findings one of
which would be in my opinion that the
this has taken too long to produce I
think when we've got a situation which
is causing people's deaths and air
pollution causes 50,000 deaths a year in
this country
I couldn't extrapolate that to radio I'm
afraid so sorry I don't know but it will
be some deaths a year caused by this I
think it's important that we produced
these reports on a quick and timely
basis and I understand I know from
previous reports made to this committee
by mr. Hallett that it was also not just
us as a council it was also outside
bodies of live Essex highways would you
delay this but I think it should be
recognized that this report should have
been produced for publication earlier
and against no reflection on the
portfolio hold of moment he's coming to
this at the very very free very recently
sorry and I can understand that in
addition I'd also like a finding that we
shouldn't be saying that
then the there are currently no
exceedances of the objectives anywhere
else in the district I'd be happy for
you to say any of our monitoring other
monitoring points the district which I
think would be much more accurate
thank you
thank you thank you very much
I think we've discussed this subject
that link this evening are members happy
or satisfied us saying with the bindings
that counselor mr. Mason is proposing
sorry counselor mr. hoy is proposing if
you could show with a show of hands Pat
okay so if we can report those findings
and I think
one month tied in
you
we got recommend it back to the
portfolio holder for that possum
challenge
delightfully decided by the can we
change put is the wording able to be
changed without without significant
delay
you
nextly well I think the emphasis to be
he where else in the district to the
monitoring points in within the district
if that can be done without significant
delay on members happy with that if that
can be implemented that would be good
thank you thank you very much um if we
can just take a five-minute break as
members have indicated
and reconvene here at half-past thank
Livan so it's not easy
okay Thank You members if I can ask you
to take your seats
counselors okay moving on to agenda item
number 7 which is the overwork program
this would have been circulated to
members or the agenda house
this part is to decide on the work plan
for the committee for the next year it's
worth bearing in mind they're on there
are ongoing projects which are not
listed but there they are the review of
the Constitution review of the ITC
contracts ultimate telephony review of
Absolution Smith chairman
I better just ask a question on this
some one of your topics you've got the
Train Standards Committee on chairman do
I need to you're done I thank you okay
okay thank you and yep so the review of
the ITC contracts ultimate telephony and
a review of the use of treasury
management advisors the reports to be
included in the treasury manager port
come into committee in July and we also
have reports on Community Safety
partnerships during the year members
will see that some some new topics have
been raised enforcement of unauthorized
adverts charging for bins for new
developments not being applied
universally the loss of income and
training standards committees needing to
take more control leadership over
training and sanctuary due back in
October November also have any members
got any comments - on those items or the
topics that have been put forward for
review over the next year counselor mr.
Hoyle sorry show them what break for a
start working again forgive me if you
did mention it in the list of ongoing
projects I was against an ongoing
project but we were promised to return
which was Building Control did you
mention that I apologize if I you did
no correct but I did promise to come
back a number way December that was it
thank you
you mean food building control oh yes
it's kind of outdated fancy yes your
honor that's just been missed
yep sorry yes that's just been missed
unfortunately cancel hook way yeah it's
just done from my memory that was to do
if they're looking to develop that work
now yes I am as a form of sort of like a
money screen coming in to counseling
okay any other comments or questions
from members
No you'll notice there as well the item
number eight on the agenda is the
methodology which is to discuss how we
take those topics forward I've discussed
this with Paul an enforcement of
unauthorized adverts we would initially
probably ask for a report to come
forward from also you've just said even
done yes from Yvonne done for members to
consider charging for bins for new
developments again we would probably
request a report from Marcus and
training we would need to agree how we
would like that one discussed and taken
forward I don't know if the members that
put that topic for would have got any
ideas on that counselor mr. Mason yeah
I'm not sure I put it forward but I've
certainly experienced the issue at the
moment I don't know how the the subjects
for training get chosen I haven't got
clue as anything other any other member
knows either because we're not involved
and it's as simple as that
we're not involved in deciding on what
the training subjects are or the content
and that's issue so maybe we ought to be
asking for a report from whoever does it
because I don't know does it on actually
how these subjects are actually chosen
as subjects and the content decide upon
thank you our members happy with that
proposal bond counseling mr. Mason
I understand it's John Bostock who
decides so we can request a report maybe
initially from in or maybe not as
probably going to inform us now I'll
pull John out the fire for this one it
yes usually me with it with the chairman
and I ask the Chairman also make
suggestions and was it the review
committee chairman of the time as I did
well for training further review for me
you
yeah hey it is jumbo stock it's been
confirmed and so put off the book okay
and so chairman can I just say it
probably is is discussed at the
standards can which about the training
that goes forward some literally to let
people training maybe it will be under
your chairman
okay so the whole idea is that it should
be at the moments I think I'm allowed to
put this food is we are presented with a
program whether or not it has any any
relevance or any wishes from the members
there's no input the dates are preset
the subjects are preset okay we could be
getting training that we don't need we
could be getting training that are not
getting training that we do need we
could be wasting an awful lot of money
and an awful lot of time it just needs
to be investigating so how and who I
don't know it's impossible
okay I think yeah we need a able to
request a report in there in the initial
phase from John bus stop and and take
those from there okay any members got
any other topics or questions on the
topics of all we've been put forward no
okay so you can sir mr. hoy so German
one of the other routes to having
something in the review committees
members of the public would it be
appropriate to ask a for traditional
Council on their Facebook page if any
members of the public have anything any
one board like recoup
that's a regarding topic that we can
review is it already
okay yeah that's that's fine anything
else nope okay so that's agenda items
seven and eight covered moving on to
number nine which is the key decisions
document have we got any spare copy that
if we have of it does anybody need a
copy or can they share a copy
ladies you you need to mention about
that feeling for those fans
why did firmly and then I suddenly think
no it's fine you need to mention about
the scene enforcement reason you have
emailed members about it sounded been
removed
yep more members got access to see the
cletus's report [ __ ] asked Paul just
to go through that with members thank
you okay members and the first one is
the Environmental Health Service claim
which is an annual one this was
originally on for the 28th of April and
has now been moved to the 30th of June
and as he says its ICT dependencies
that's held that up moving on we've got
two new ones number 517 the South Essex
strategic housing market assessment 217
addendum and then the South Essex
Economic Development needs assessment
2017
counselor mr. mason's just to just a
comment share them particularly on the
schlocko 517 I've already read it so I'm
a little bit surprised we haven't got it
in front of what in front of members
generally anybody able to come out come
the look into that I can look into I
think give us a sum in the echo the bin
Ricky is published
[Music]
and can you raise that with these Thomas
and will hold that and report back
Thank You counsel mr. horn
thank you lady eyes at the back of your
head there are phrases in other areas
where I'm 12 rated on these I'm getting
a little bit annoyed about the just
changing the date I know you've made a
reference or mr. Ganz made a reference
to effective for 17s being delayed and
he says there are CP pendants have held
up why isn't the original date there I
still think they ought to be publishing
the original date though their original
target dates and where it's been changed
it should be noted thank you yeah I'll
make sure the in future they did a libel
over them because that was the
understanding that we'd come to okay
thank you remembers any other questions
no okay moving on to agenda item number
11 which is exclusion of person public
there are none so I won't need to read
out the notice